Hi, I'm Zack Ellis interviewing
Heather Meeker for FOSSDA, the
Free and Open Source Stories
Digital Archive.
So Heather, I want to start off by
asking you to tell me a little bit
about yourself.
Well, I am a lawyer and a venture
capitalist, and both in the area
of open source software.
And I've been practicing law for
nearly 30 years, mostly in this
area.
And then I've been doing VC work
for about three years in this
area.
I have a checkered past beyond
that, but maybe not all that
relevant to what we're doing.
I've done a lot of stuff in life.
Law was my third career and my
best one.
So, but that's what I'm doing
these days.
Fantastic.
So law and venture capital, so
you've seen different sides of the
open source world, it sounds like.
Yeah, definitely.
And, you know, one of the reasons
that I got to that dual role is
that a lot of what I was doing as
a lawyer ended up being more like
business counseling.
So that is actually a more natural
evolution than you might think.
So these days, it's a little hard
to separate the two, except for
you get paid differently for doing
the two things.
So how did that get started for
you?
And it sounds like, were you, walk
me through a little bit, maybe of
the high level, like the
beginnings of your career into
when you started to get involved
in software, in open source?
Well, so I actually was a computer
programmer in the 1980s.
I know that just sounds absolutely
ancient now.
Doesn't sound ancient to me, but
it's all a matter of perspective.
And I got into that because there
was a lot of demand for people to
work in particularly applications
programming.
When I graduated from college, and
I didn't have a degree in computer
science, and in fact, most people
didn't have degrees in computer
science, you couldn't really get a
degree in computer science, except
for maybe, you know, some schools.
I went to a liberal arts college,
and I think they had a computer
science major, but you had to kind
of cobble it together.
So I had actually learned
programming as a kid, because my
father taught me the basics of it.
And then when I was in college, I
took some computer science
classes, basically, because the
computer science lab was air
conditioned.
And I went to summer school, and
it was really hot.
Plus, I was interested in
programming, you know, I thought
it was kind of cool.
So I graduated, and I quickly like
moved into computer programming,
because there was a lot of
opportunity in that area.
And nobody required a degree in it
at that time, maybe because there
just weren't enough people.
So you could basically go and put
your hand up and say, I'm
interested.
And if you had a college degree,
or at least had been to college
for some amount of time, that was
a real plus, right.
So I worked as a programmer for
about four years.
And then I went off and did some
other stuff.
I was a professional musician for
a while, opened a business.
And then after I went to law
school, I realized that actually
the law around computer software
was very interesting to me because
I had this background.
So that's a long way of saying
that when I started practicing
law, I immediately started
focusing on computer software
licensing as a practice.
And then very soon after that,
people started to become aware of
open source.
And they started asking me
questions about it.
So, you know, I had to figure out
the answers to the questions
because there weren't many answers
floating around there at that
time.
So I just, you know, started to
try to figure out what the answers
were.
And when you're in an organization
and you know 10% more than the
person in the next room, you're
the expert, you know, that's just
the way the world works.
And so people kept asking me
questions and I kept trying to
answer them and building up my
knowledge.
And that's how I got into it.
I would say that the reason I put
that effort in was that I just
thought it was really interesting.
I mean, it was something that I
had never seen before.
And there's really not been a lot
like it in the law because it's
just kind of a grassroots movement
and from a legal point of view, it
was very like messy and hard to
understand, which I think most
lawyers love stuff like that,
right?
We're puzzle solvers.
And this was a really interesting
puzzle that moreover had something
to do with a topic that I was
interested in.
So that's how I got involved in it
as a lawyer.
And then after practicing for many
years, I got more interested in
how to make business models work
in this area.
And that's how I got into the
venture capital.
So it was kind of initially an
interest in computer science or
programming, but that kind of came
from your dad introducing you to
computers at a really early age.
It did.
Well, just out of curiosity, what
did he do?
And how did that come about where
he was like, oh, yeah, he's going
to love this.
He was actually a programmer.
And that doesn't sound
extraordinary today at all, but it
was incredibly extraordinary then.
I mean, he actually worked in a
think tank kind of place and they
were starting to use computers to
solve problems, which, you know,
people just hadn't even done
before that.
And so he used to take me to work
and I would see the computers with
the big tape drives on them.
And it's like a lot of really
amusing stuff about going to these
places and being exposed to that.
But when I was a kid and people
would ask me what my father did
for a living, you know, I started
saying he was like a spy, right,
because it was easier to explain
than telling people that he was a
computer data processor, which is
what he told me to say.
Right.
No one understood what that was.
And and so I got a really early
view into that.
And of course, he did not have a
technical education either,
though, because at that time,
nobody did basically.
Yeah.
So then so then you started
studying programming.
What like what what kept you
interested in computer science?
Computer like programming is.
It's an experience like almost
nothing else, like when you are
writing a program, you are in
total control, right, subject to
the rules of the language and the
environment you're in, you tell
the computer exactly what to do.
If the computer doesn't do what
you ask it to do, it's your fault.
Right.
I mean, that's not always true.
It's almost always true.
So that's like this experience.
It's like pure engineering in a
way.
Like you're not even you're not
even really bounded by the
physical world in programming.
Like it's like being a little
megalomaniac, you know, it's like
really exciting for that reason.
Also, it's one of the most
absorbing things I've ever done.
Like when I was a coder, I would
go to work and I'd get there, you
know, at eight in the morning and
then at five I would look up and
the day would be over.
And it was almost as if no time
had passed because I was so
focused on what I was doing.
And I don't think I've ever
experienced anything else quite
like that.
Nothing else I've ever done in my
life, either for money or for fun,
has has absorbed me that much.
And I really loved it for that
reason, but also got kind of burnt
out on it for that reason.
And and I stopped doing it.
Not sure whether that was a good
idea or a bad idea, but but it was
what happened, you know.
So that's what I loved about it.
It was just you got to solve
puzzles however you you know, and
you were only really bounded by
your ingenuity in doing that.
I also thought coding was a very
creative activity, and I'm not
sure everybody thinks that.
But but you have like so much
control over how you do things.
I just found that fascinating.
And then so that kind of that that
that sort of freedom and
creativity kind of and just
natural draw to it kind of kept
you there.
But then you then you left and
went into law kind of but for
programming and computer science.
Tell me a little bit about kind of
the departure from programming and
then into law and kind of what
attracted you to to law.
And then we'll marry those
together with open source.
But tell me a little bit.
Well, there was another step in
there.
I I went to music school.
I went to a basically a trade
school is a one year program.
And I went to learn to play drums
because I had been, you know,
learning drums.
And I had gotten the idea that I
wanted to be a musician.
By the way, that's a bad idea.
But not because it's really fun to
play music, but it's a terrible
career.
Anyway, a terrible career.
Anyway, so I went to this school
and and and then I started working
professionally as a musician and I
I opened a rehearsal studio.
working professionally as a
musician and I I opened a
rehearsal studio.
So I had this little business.
And and and then I just realized,
well, this is an awful career.
You know, You know, there is
really no future in this because
you know how they say in the
entertainment industry, industry,
it's who, you know, that's not
just like Sour Graves.
It's really who, you know, and I
didn't know anybody.
Right.
And I suppose there are some
people who are like super
brilliant, who can just make it
without any connections.
I was not one of those people.
I mean, I was competent, but not
great.
By the way, I in music school, I I
met people who were really
brilliant.
And I and I realized I'm not one
of those people.
Like I am not a super talented
musician.
Right.
And that's OK.
I still enjoy doing it.
But but they understood that about
myself.
You know, I I could do it OK.
But I would never be like this
great player.
So so I decide, OK, I'm not going
to do that anymore.
Plus, I was about nearly 30 at
that time.
And it's kind of a a young kid's
profession.
And and so what I did was I got a
job as a as a temp secretary at a
at a record label.
I knew someone who worked at a at
a record label.
I knew someone who worked at the
record label, and they were and I
really needed a job because I
didn't have any money.
were and I really needed a job
because I didn't have any money.
I didn't have any health
insurance.
It was And and insurance.
It was awful.
And and so I started was awful.
And and so I started working there
and they put me in the legal
department and actually really
enjoyed working in the legal
department.
So then they made me a paralegal
and then they made me a lawyer.
Then they made me a paralegal.
One One of the paralegals left.
They made me a paralegal.
And then and then I I looked
around and I thought I could make
a lot more money doing the same
work if I just went to law school.
Now, that's a huge commitment of
time and money.
And and so that's that's what got
me interested in law.
Actually, you know, I was doing
some work in that area and I
thought it was really interesting.
And by the way, I thought that I
would become an entertainment
lawyer because I had been working
at an entertainment business.
But when I got to law school and I
realized you could work in
technology and and that actually
there was a big crossover to
entertainment, I thought I found
the perfect place for me.
I graduated law school in 1994 and
basically the World Wide Web
happened for most people in about
95 or 96.
And so there was something going
on that they called convergence,
meaning technology and media
coming together.
And that was just me.
I was right at the intersection of
those things.
And when I found out you could
work in that area, I thought I
will never, never wanted to do
anything else.
This this was perfect for me.
Well, so I'm curious what you
talked about, like being really
consumed by programming early on
and then all of a sudden,
seemingly by surprise, loving
legal.
What was it about legal?
And I'm curious if you saw any
similarities or differences
between the joy that you got from
the legal work and from
programming.
Well, you know, there were some
similarities in in the in the joy
I got from it.
There are also a huge number of
similarities between programming
and legal, like, for instance, if
you're a if you're a transactional
lawyer like I was, I was doing
deals.
When you write contracts, you're
writing rules for people.
When you're programming, you're
writing rules for computers to
execute.
There are a huge number of
parallels between the two.
So I don't know, maybe I just like
writing rules.
But but the kind of enjoyment I
got was pretty different.
Like it's it's they're both
intellectual tasks, but they're
very different intellectual tasks.
Like computer programming is like
pure problem solving and legal
work is all more analysis.
And and you have to deal with a
lot more vagueness.
Like computer programming pretty
much is what it is.
And you can't as a programmer, you
usually can't change that.
Like you're in an environment and
there's well, you know, for people
like me who are applications
programmers, you just given the
environment, you deal with the
rules you're given for for law.
The rules are fuzzy, which is why
the world has so many lawyers, you
know, so it's a different kind of
task and much, much more human
oriented.
I mean, programmers just sit there
all day in front of a machine and
you don't have to interact with
any human being.
Lawyers have to, you know, that's
actually about client service and
you have to interact with people.
I'm curious when you first started
to get into law and saw this
convergence of tech and law and
entertainment on top of that.
Who are some of the early
influential figures in your career
at that stage?
It's kind of hard to say because I
was mostly blazing my own path.
I mean, I had colleagues who
taught me a lot, but that was more
about how to practice law.
Law Law is a weird profession in
that you go to professional
school, which is three years long,
and they teach you nothing about
practicing law.
They teach you some stuff about
law, but not about being a lawyer
at all.
They're basically teaching you to
be a judge.
So most of us don't become judges
and we go into private practice
and then you have to learn how to
be a lawyer.
So I had wonderful colleagues who
taught me how to be a lawyer.
But as far as the open source
expertise, you know, we were kind
of writing the rules in a way like
we were looking at these licenses
and trying to figure out how to
like plug them into a legal
context.
And one of the reasons I enjoyed
the area is there just wasn't
anything out there about it.
So one of the things I started
doing was writing about it because
I really like to write.
And I thought, OK, there are no
materials.
I'll I'll just write them.
And so I was kind of on my own for
a lot of it.
I mean, I've had some friends, you
know, whom I've been able to
bounce things off of, but I wasn't
like I don't know, there wasn't
one person who was like guiding me
at all.
Yeah, yeah.
Like you said, it was kind of
blazing your own path and it was
new.
And And like you were kind of
people would clients would ask you
questions.
You'd have to figure it out.
Yeah, there were there weren't
answers, really.
You had to just kind of
extrapolate from the basic legal
answers that you knew.
And that was it was scary and
challenging.
And but that's kind of what I
liked about it, too.
Yeah.
Can you remember like the the
first time that you remember
hearing about open source and what
that was and that is something
different than typical way?
I think a client sent me a copy of
one of the permissive licenses
like the BSD license, which is a
very short license.
It's like a couple of paragraphs,
two, three paragraphs.
And and it didn't look like
anything I'd ever seen.
And then they were asking, is this
OK to use?
And there was no one around me to
answer that question.
So then I started reading
everything I could about what was
out there.
And there was some stuff written
about it, but it was mostly what I
would call advocacy.
So there were free software
advocates who were saying, you
know, software should be open.
But that wasn't legal analysis.
Right.
And so the the legal objective
legal analysis was not out there
at all.
So that's what I had to start, you
know, trying to figure out.
And there were other people trying
to figure it out, too.
But we weren't really working
together at that point.
So, yeah, I'm sure it was somebody
sending me like the BSD license, a
client asking.
I don't remember what client it
was, but client sends me BSD
license.
It says, hey, is this OK?
And I got to answer that question
is actually a very difficult
question at the time.
Hmm.
So what so what was I mean, what
was that like to start to see some
of these other types of licenses
come up and you're going through
trying to look at research that's
out there?
And what were the what were the
challenging aspects?
And how did that kind of evolve
into something that became more?
I don't know if formal is the
right word, but they're like there
are now practices and standard
licenses around open source.
Like, how did that kind of evolve
over time?
Well, I should probably explain
that when you're a lawyer and
someone asks you a question,
they'll present you with some
facts and then you either know
what the law is or you look it up,
like you do some research and you
maybe you read a case or you read
a statute or something like that.
And then you apply one to the
other and you give an answer.
So in open source, that didn't
work at all.
There there were there were like
there's copyright law, but it
doesn't tell you how to interpret
open source licenses.
There's contract law, but it
doesn't tell you a lot about that
either.
So I was looking at this set of
facts like this license, and then
I had to go, OK, what do I know
about the law that would ever
apply to this thing?
Because Because it's just a new
thing.
And I there was there were no
cases to read.
There were no statutes to read.
There was there weren't even any
like law review articles to read.
And and so, you know, I just kind
of had to reason from first
principles about it.
And and lawyers.
That scares lawyers a lot.
Like when they don't have rules,
they get freaked out.
They like rules.
Right.
So the experience was like walking
out on a wire, you know.
And and by the way, there were
some people at the time and
probably still some some people,
some lawyers who just would not
deal with it at all because it was
too weird and too new.
And they felt that it was risky to
give advice about it.
But but my clients had questions.
You know, I couldn't just say, oh,
no, I don't know the answer to
that.
Like, you have to figure it out.
Hmm.
And then so so what started to
happen after that?
Like what happened next?
I mean, after you started to write
about it, you started to get more
started to see this more.
What happened?
Well, first of all, I started to
meet other people who are
interested in the topic.
And so now we're like in the late
1990s, early 2000s.
And and so now I'm meeting a few
other lawyers who seem to be
knowledgeable about it.
And so, first of all, some
communities developed around that
so that we could bounce things off
each other.
And and then, you know, I started
getting some reputation for
knowing.
You know about this thing and
people would just call me out of
the blue, you know, because they
they were really at sea trying to
figure this stuff out.
And then and then what really
developed over the next 10 years
and continues to develop today is
best practices around dealing with
the licenses, because there's
still not a lot of direct law on
them.
But there are practices that
people agree are best practices.
So that's that's really what
happened next was some development
of the law, but mostly a
development of a way that people
generally did things in order to
deal with the licenses.
What what was it like when you
started to meet some of those
other players in the open source
space?
And tell me a little bit.
I know you've said to me before
that there's there's different
types of stakeholders in the open
source community.
Tell me a little bit about like
the types of stakeholders and some
of those early interactions you
had as you started to meet like
the world of players, if you will.
Well, I met clients who were
interested in it.
And so they were actually usually
other lawyers who wanted to learn
about it.
So I was helping them learn as I
learned about it.
I I also had clients who were
engineers and they're developers.
So they're the people actually
creating the software.
They're the most important people,
by the way.
The lawyers are just, you know, on
along for the ride.
Right.
So I met a lot of engineers who
actually interested in writing
open source software.
I met other lawyers just, you
know, who were not clients or
colleagues who were interested in
it.
And I would say maybe the
relationship I had with them was a
little bit of frenemies, you you
know, because we were competing
with each other.
But but on the other hand, there
weren't so many of us that we
could really afford not to
collaborate, you know.
And and then like there developed
a lot of other categories of
people involved, like community
managers.
So these may not actually be
developers, but maybe they're
people who help bring open source
developers together.
There were business people who
wanted to, you know, use open
source in their business or use
open source as a business tool.
So those were those are some of
the main stakeholders that I
started to interact with over
time.
Yeah.
Did any of those kind of early
projects like really pique your
interest or when did you start to
see open source as something
transformative?
I really saw it as transformative
almost from the beginning.
I did not realize and I'm not sure
very many people would have
realized at that time how huge it
would get.
But it was just so different from
everything else that you learned
as a technology lawyer.
Like if you do a regular software
license, you know, it has a
particular form and some terms
that you would expect.
So there's a there's like an
industry practice about that.
Open source is like bizarro world
licensing.
It's like exactly the opposite.
It's It's like giving away rights
and forcing people to give away
rights instead of just like normal
licensing is like just granting
the minimum little thing necessary
to get the deal done.
But like being as stingy as
possible.
That's like what you do with
proprietary license with open
source.
You You just like here it is.
Do whatever you want with it.
And there are very few
limitations.
If you got to really think hard
about like what what are those?
Those they're not really
limitations like conditions.
What does conditions mean and how
do you comply with those?
So it was just totally different.
And I like that about it because
there's a lot of mental gymnastics
like involved in trying to switch
from one paradigm to the other.
What how how do those differences
between open source and kind of
proprietary systems?
What kind of changes does that
create, both from a business
context, from how people interact?
I'm going to see it's huge.
I it's huge.
I mean, you know, if you look back
before so open source is used
before.
Open source is used by everybody
is used before.
now.
Like almost everyone in the
technology industry now actually
contributes to it.
I mean, it's everywhere.
We're using it right this minute
to do this interview.
It's in your phone.
It's everywhere, right?
And if you go back, I guess, 25
years, the notion that that
private companies would do
collaborate was not an idea.
I mean, it wasn't a thing that it
wasn't a thing.
Right.
And and today you have all these
like big organizations and
companies collaborating on things
and giving stuff away.
And that just wasn't done.
I would say open source changed
the entire face of technology
because it it changed a paradigm
for how people interact.
You know, they were just strictly
competitors and now they're
collaborators.
And even there are there are only
like maybe two, three companies
that are known for not doing it
now.
Right.
If you go back 25 years, like no
one was doing it.
They were terrified about what
these licenses meant and
everything.
So it's completely been absorbed
in business.
And that, you know, if you believe
in markets, which I do because I
studied economics and all that
stuff, that wouldn't happen unless
it worked.
Right.
It actually works as a paradigm.
Like it produced a lot of really
great stuff.
And over that time, people became
convinced of that and they
overcame their fear about these
licensing paradigms they didn't
understand.
So they got over the fear and then
it really changed their behavior.
So to me, it's changed everything
about the way the technology
industry operates.
Kind of looking back on your
interactions with clients, and you
mentioned earlier that kind of as
being a lawyer is almost also
being a business advisor.
Whether, you know, what if any
moments kind of stand out in your
mind where whether it was was
resistance to the idea of open
source or where it just like
clicked or like how you approach
that?
That's a tough question.
I don't remember one instance so
much as it seems to me like I've
spent decades now talking people
off the ledge because they're
frightened.
Everyone's frightened of things
they don't understand.
Right.
So I spent many, many hours just
explaining how things worked and
trying to reduce people's level of
fear.
And by the way, that's not a
normal task for a lawyer.
Like most lawyers have the task of
identifying risks and warning
people about stuff.
My career has been almost the
opposite, like saying, no, you
really don't need to worry about
this.
Yes, it's a theoretical risk, but
in the end of the day, it won't
matter.
And and so that's what I remember
is like years and years of doing
that.
Where do you think that comes
from?
That kind of opposite disposition
that you that you seem to have?
Well, maybe I, you know, maybe I
never should have been a lawyer.
You know, that's that's certainly,
you know, open to question.
Right.
Because I think my personality is
not is a little different from
most lawyers.
I'm very practical.
And and maybe that's why I liked
programming, too.
You know, I'm I'm a very practical
type.
I think I am an engineer at heart.
And so I like to create stuff and
I like to create procedures and so
forth.
And I like to build stuff.
And and that's not really a lawyer
personality.
I don't know where I got that, but
I don't remember getting it.
I think I just came into the
situation with it.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
You mentioned before, though, it's
both like maybe you like creating
rules, but you also mentioned how
there is or it seemed to me like
almost a certain freedom, at least
when you were you were
programming, where you're not
bound, but, you know, by the real
world.
It's like this pure it's this pure
creative endeavor.
Yeah.
Well, to me, that's what it was.
So so talk me through some of the
other kind of inflection points in
your career as you then progressed
as you met.
Can you meet more people?
What were some of the main
inflection points from there?
Well, I changed law firms a couple
of times.
You know, I was at one place and I
just felt like I wasn't succeeding
there.
And that was an important life
lesson.
And it was kind of painful, but it
turned out OK.
You know, part of the problem I
had, I think, was that being an
open source lawyer was not really
a thing.
Right.
And and the people I worked with
didn't even understand, like they
didn't even think it was
important.
They They didn't particularly
value this expertise.
My clients valued it, but the
people I was working for didn't.
And so I just thought I need to be
somewhere where I can just kind of
carve my own path because I didn't
want to go on the paths that were
available.
And nobody was going to go say,
oh, we have an open source expert.
Isn't that a great thing?
Right.
Today they would.
But but at the time, no, like it
just wasn't recognized as a career
path.
So that was a little painful
because I had to move and I felt
kind of like a failure.
And but it was also a real
learning experience.
And, you know, what I would say
about that is that everybody goes
through those things.
Like if you look at people and
they seem to just have succeeded
one in one thing after another,
nobody does that.
Right.
Everybody crashes and burns.
And and it's it's about how you
react to that.
It's not you know, it's not you
can't avoid it in life.
Right.
You're going to have setbacks.
Um, but I'm extremely persistent
and I was very interested in the
topic.
And I just thought, well, I must
find a situation where I can do
this.
The other thing is, um, I made a
decision along the line that what
I wanted from my law practice was
to be the best lawyer I could be
like.
And I wanted to be the best in
this area.
You know, I wanted to to pursue
excellence.
And that is not the same as
pursuing money.
I mean, they do interact a lot at
a good law firm.
Right.
But but I could have done other
things to make more money.
And I mean, don't get me wrong.
I've been a partner at a big law
firm for many years, and it's, you
know, very well paying job.
But but that was an important
choice.
You know, I could have gone in a
different direction.
I probably wouldn't have been as
specialized.
I would have done different kinds
of work.
But what gets me out of bed every
morning at my desk is not like,
oh, I'm going to make a lot a lot
of money today or even I'm going
to make a lot of money for my
clients today.
It's It's like I just want to do
something really difficult and
interesting.
Like, that's what I wanted to do.
And it's important to know, you
know, what you want out of a
career.
And you never know it when you're
starting out.
You learn that over time.
So so I made choices that led me
down that path.
And so what did that look like to
then, you know, you left the the
law firm felt like they didn't
necessarily appreciate open source
in the way that you did.
And here's the thing, that there
is this opportunity to dive into
it more and pursue it.
So what what did you do?
Well, in fact, they told me and
this is this is kind of
astonishing at this point.
But I was told we don't really
need people.
This is at a technology law firm,
too.
We don't really need people with
software expertise.
I mean, it's like such a
ridiculous statement because then
the entire world, like as Andreas
said, like software ate the world.
Right.
Like, why would you even say that?
But that was just that that
situation just was what it was.
And and so, you know, I left and
just went to another firm and I
went to a place where they were a
lot more agnostic about what your
practice was.
Basically, I interviewed at this
place and I was talking to the guy
that ran the firm and he asked me
what I did.
And And I said, oh, I'm a
specialist in open source.
And I explained something about my
practice.
And he said, I have no idea what
you're talking about, but I have a
couple of questions for you.
Do you have clients?
I said, oh, yeah, I've got a lot
of clients.
Do they pay you?
I said, oh, yeah, they pay me.
They're glad to pay me.
He's like, great, you know.
And so I really needed an
environment like that.
By the way, props were due.
That was Greenberg, Trorig.
And and they they were just so
wonderful because they gave me
this opportunity to make my own
way.
And And and that was that was huge
for me.
You know, I it was it's scary
because then you've got to
perform.
Right.
But but that was the kind of place
where they were like, look, if
you've got a good practice, we
welcome you.
And it was it was less about their
mission than about the mission of
the people that worked there.
And what did that feel like to
kind of have this, again, like
antithesis kind of thing where it
was like, oh, it's almost like,
you know, you're a VC.
Oh, do you have traction?
OK, well, there must be something
here.
I don't I don't know if I get it
or not, but the market says that
that there's.
Yeah, exactly.
Like, Like, what was what was that
like?
And what did that feel like to
have someone kind of embrace you?
Oh, it was it was great.
I really felt appreciated and I
really needed that at that point,
you know, because I had been
through this, you know, sort of
difficult transition.
And and I and I, like I said, I'm
forever grateful that there was
that opportunity, you know,
because I could have not run into
that opportunity.
And another thing is that, like,
it matters how people run
businesses.
You know, it's not you hear all
the corporate messaging in a place
you work.
And that matters.
Like the culture matters.
And that particular business, like
the first firm I worked at, you
would go to a company event and
they would say they had a mission
statement.
Here's our mission statement.
Come along for the ride.
And then I went to Greenberg and
they and we would have a meeting
and they would say and the
management would say, how can we
help you succeed?
Like, you know what you're doing,
OK?
We want to hire you unless you
knew what you were doing.
How do we help you succeed?
And that was like so empowering,
right?
It's a great way to run a business
if you can run a business that
way.
And and it was it was a great
feeling because I really like just
having the freedom to to go in my
own direction.
Could you talk a little bit about
kind of from from that period of
then really diving into practicing
like open source law to becoming a
VC in the open source community
and how in the world did that
happen?
And that's a good question.
Yeah, yeah.
So I didn't really intend that to
happen.
But but the the the person who
runs the VC firm, Joseph Jacks, is
he's called JJ.
He just like contacted me out of
the blue basically one day and
said, hey, I'm starting a fund
that's around open source.
Do you want to be part of it?
And my first inclination was, what
do you want me for?
Just I'm a lawyer.
But then I talked to him more and
I thought, oh, actually, this does
make a lot of sense because I had
been spending a lot of time
counseling people on business
models.
And I I almost didn't realize how
much of my time I was spending
doing that.
And there was this event that took
place.
And this is kind of inside
baseball, but hopefully I can make
it understandable.
Somebody I knew came to me and
asked me to write this license, a
new kind of license.
And they asked me to do it for
free.
It wasn't a client engagement.
And I said, sure, you know,
because I always help people do
stuff, you know.
And and so I wrote this thing or I
actually led the drafting on is
probably more accurate.
And it got released and it was
enormously controversial.
This was something called the
Commons Clause.
And and I was roundly criticized
for doing this.
I mean, you know, there was all
sorts of trolling and flame wars
and stuff over this thing.
And and I thought to myself at
that point, oh, my goodness, you
know, I did this for free.
And, you know, no good deed goes
unpunished and all this sort of
thing.
But then it turned out that
although that particular project
didn't really fly for a variety of
reasons, people wanted to do
similar things.
And they were very interested in
like the concept that this
involved, a concept I didn't come
up with.
I just wrote the thing.
Right.
People told me what they want and
I wrote it for them.
And so I was just a craftsman
there.
But then people started coming to
me and saying, well, I want to do
something like that.
And And and so over the course of
maybe a year, I probably did a
project like that for several
dozen companies.
I I mean, that's a lot of
companies.
You know, that's a lot of clients
in that amount of time.
So so I that involved a lot of
discussion about business models.
So I kind of fell into this thing
just because somebody asked me to
do something for them.
And and then all of a sudden, like
I was the person doing this thing.
And I have to say that, you know,
that changed my whole career
because I started doing different
kind of work.
And that's kind of how I got into
the business model counseling more
than just kind of the pure
licensing analysis.
I did a favor for someone which
seemed to be a very bad idea at
the beginning, but it turned out
to be a very good idea.
I mean, maybe not not so different
than the first client who said,
hey, what do you think about this
license?
I don't know.
Let me go look.
Oh, absolutely.
Because like this was also new.
This is new territory, too.
But and and I guess, you know,
there are probably it would have
been a lot of people who would
have said, no way I won't do that,
particularly for free.
But but I said, yeah, sure.
Sign me up.
There might be some some similar
ethos there around free free and
open source software.
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, my my whole philosophy,
like for all these years has been
if somebody asked me to help, I
help them if I can.
Like and whether it's going to
result in pain, work or not is
kind of secondary for me.
And I'm not sure.
Again, I'm not sure that's a way
to make the most money, you know,
or be.
But actually, I think it does make
you successful.
Like paying it forward really
works in a service business.
And it's also makes you happier, I
think, because you get to help
people.
I like helping people.
Where do you think you'd be
without open source if open source
never existed?
A starving drummer?
No, I might be a starving
musician, but more likely I'd just
be doing like M&A deals, which is
fine.
You know, I've done tons of them,
but but it it wouldn't have been
as wild a ride.
Open source is crazy.
Like every time you think that
you've seen everything, something
absolutely crazy happens.
Somebody is doing something
totally nuts.
And you wake up and you read the
news and you're like, what?
How could this happen?
And and it's it's scary, but fun.
It doesn't happen so much in like
M&A deals.
Would it be worth in the last few
minutes that we have here talking
about Google versus Oracle?
That was a big deal and you were
involved.
Yeah.
Yeah, Yeah, that was an amazing
experience.
It was.
I mean, I think for most.
Well, there aren't so many
software copyright lawyers running
around out there.
But for those of us in that area,
that was like the case of the
century.
And it was also between two big
companies that had a lot of money
to litigate.
And I loved working with Google.
I mean, they're a great client to
work with.
And I just got it was so great to
get to work on a landmark thing
like that.
And And I also thought it was
really important to the industry.
And I'm really glad we won.
Could you, you know, for the sake
of history, I mean, could you talk
just what were the implications of
the case?
What was at stake in kind of what
was it about?
Well, on a on a doctrinal level,
it was about whether you could
copy the interface of some
software in order to reengineer
it.
So so if if if there's some
software and you don't like that
software for a variety of reasons
like you don't like the way it
works or you don't like the
licensing for it or whatever, can
you take the interface for it and
redo it yourself?
Because that's basically what
Google did with Android and as
opposed to Java, which was what
Oracle owned.
And and there was and before that
case in the software industry,
pretty much everyone assumed you
could do that and not have
liability.
And then this lawsuit happened.
And in fact, the law was not very
clear about it.
And because you had two parties
with a lot of money to litigate,
you know, there was just every
issue got, you know, argued to the
max.
Right.
And eventually, the Supreme Court
decided that that Google could do
what they did in that case.
But but the decision was, I think,
unfortunately, a little bit
limited to its facts, pretty much,
which was that they could do that
in that case.
But that doesn't mean that you
could go to the next situation and
also do it.
It was under something called a
fair use doctrine, which is very
fact specific.
And, you know, ironically, one of
the first I remember the first
professional lecture I gave as a
lawyer when I was an associate was
on the fair use doctrine.
And I had written a paper on it in
law school.
And then I ended up doing this
huge case on it.
So that was interesting because
it's only because I wrote this
paper in law school that I kind of
knew that defense like the back of
my hand.
And then, you know, I got totally
steeped in it for the 10 years of
that case, you know, working on it
on and off.
What what did it mean to you to
work on a case like that?
Well, it's great for cocktail
party conversations like there's
it's something that people outside
of my sort of immediate sphere may
have heard of.
Right.
Whereas open source stuff like
most of them haven't really heard
of it.
So and I think it's it's
understandable to people.
So that's that's good.
I thought it was hugely important
case because if you can't rewrite
software to suit your needs, then
I don't know what that would even
mean.
I think what it would have meant
is that you if you can't do that,
then it would stifle innovation a
huge amount.
Just to give an example, like
Linux, which is the operating
system that's open source site
that was created because for in
exactly the same kind of project,
they took the interface for Unix,
which was a proprietary operating
system, and then just and rewrote
it.
They rewrote a new system to that
to Unix's specifications to avoid
the licensing issues with Unix.
And so if you couldn't do that.
In a way, we wouldn't have had the
open source movement at all.
A lot of open source software is
actually re-implementation of
proprietary software.
So that's one reason why it was
hugely important to open source.
In that sort of vein and kind of
coming to a wrap here, I mean,
where would the world be without
open source?
How has open source changed the
world?
And why does it matter?
Why does it matter to you?
I guess without Linux, we would
all be just using Windows and Mac
OS, I guess, or maybe Unix.
Unix.
And one thing that would mean is
that the developing world would
have less access to software
access to software because they'd
have to pay for every copy.
The developing world couldn't,
like, localize software for their
own languages, and we would not
have had this sea languages, and
we would not have had this sea
change in business where people
now look, people now ask
businesses to be collaborative
with each other, as opposed to
just fighting with each other and
competing with each other.
I other.
I think it's it's it's changed the
technology world and it's changed
the business world.
I once did this talk called, I
think, like, it's a wonderful it's
changed the business world.
I once did this talk called, I
think, like, it's a wonderful
Linux or something.
Or and and it was like, it's a
wonderful life, like asking what
would the world be like without
open open source?
And of course, it was dreary.
Right, dreary.
Right, right.
Doom and gloom.
Yeah.
What What are you most proud of?
What are you most proud of when
you look back on on your career or
anything else that you'd want to
share kind of in closing?
or anything else that you'd want
to share kind of in closing?
I guess I'm most proud of what I
the knowledge I've shared with
people.
That's people.
That's really it's really
important to me to teach other
people what you know.
I mean, and even if you only know
10 percent more, it's OK, right,
to teach other people.
To teach other people.
teach other people.
And that's what I'm most proud
that I was able to develop a
career where I was able to do that
and still have a successful
career.
Like, I'm glad I was able to give
so much away, because when you
look back over it, I think that's
what gives you satisfaction is
like, what did you do for other
people?
And and I think I've I've done
that.
I've certainly given away a lot of
books and videos and all the
knowledge that I could.
Absolutely.
Anything else before we wrap?
No, that's it.
I mean, it's been it's been really
fun talking about this.
I don't get asked to talk about
myself that much.
So, of course, everyone loves
talking about themselves.
But it was fun to look back over
over the whole thing and, you
know, try to figure out what the
story arc is.
Absolutely.
Well, Heather, absolute pleasure
and honor.
And thank you for your time and
contributing your story.
Well, thanks for talking to me
today.
Absolutely.